he attacks the rim like a rock concert
he blocks shots with bass aaron price is
a six foot seven spectacle when he plays
the cello
you just got dunked on by a nerd dude
like you got blocked off the glass by a
nerd
welcome to the aaron price jam session
he can play the piano the guitar
the drums
and a second chair cellist in the
liberty orchestra just getting to kick
it with all my orchestra friends and all
my band mates it's super fun when i get
to sit and talk about you know uh you
know why certain guitar strings are
better than others and i have friends in
almost every aspect of you know just
kind of like life so they they help
guide me along the way in an era of
young athlete specialization erin is
especially versatile in a day and age
where kids
kind of just
they select one thing to do to try to be
good at i think with him he's got a
plethora of
other things that he can do that he
works at and he really really works hard
at and he's pretty good at all of it
this price is soaring as a scholar and a
baller after missing his sophomore year
due to transfer rules and junior season
due to covet cancellation this is his
only year on varsity since we start
school at seven angela let's go get
shots about five in the morning just
every day working on his craft and you
can see like when we play it's coming
out and showing the 17 year old is
ranked 23rd out of 800 students in his
class but wants to play division one
basketball of course among other things
i'm about to take my cello with me to
college i want to take my guitar with me
to college and
you know hopefully i can bother my
roommate a little bit uh you know hear
me hearing me practice in the next room
the world should prepare for price he's
ultra gifted giving his best
and can do just about anything